Brazil's presidential election will be settled...
...in a second round of voting on October the 30th.
That's after no candidate...
...took an absolute majority of votes on Sunday.
With nearly all of the ballots counted,...
...former president Luis Inacio Lula da Silva,...
...who is simply known as Lula, has 48%,...
...while incumbent Jair Bolsonaro...
...received an unexpectedly strong 43%.
Moderate Simone Tebet is trading with 4%.
Lula spoke to supporters in the commercial capital Sao Paolo,...
...putting an optimistic spin on the result.
I always believed that we would win these elections,...
...and what I can tell you is that we are going to win these elections.
This is just extra time for us.
The race has proven tighter than most surveys suggested,...
...revitalizing incumbent President Jair Bolsonaro's campaign...
...after he insisted that polls could not be trusted.
His surprising showing dashed Lula's hopes of a quick win.
I think we will form a good alliance to win the elections.